public sénat mort à tous et merci de
nous retrouver pour cette première
partie de 24 heures c'est là tout de
suite je vous propose de suivre
l'audition de rémy pflimlin le pdg de
france télévisions il a été entendu
mardi par la commission de la culture du
sénat sur le projet de loi relatifs à
l'indépendance de l'audiovisuel public
ce texte prévoit est bien de nommer les
pdg de france télévisions mais aussi de
radio france par le président du csa et
non plus par le président de la
république comme l'avait souhaité
nicolas sarkozy alors voyons tout de
suite ce que rémy pflimlin pense de ce
texte et on se retrouve tout de suite
après du de la façon dont est conforté
l'indépendance du service public à
travers cette loi
l'indépendance qui est une valeur
absolument cardinal pour les entreprises
de service public et qui doit évidemment
être un élément clef de la relation avec
nos concitoyens en notant d'ailleurs que
cette indépendance est lié évidemment au
mode de nomination d
président de l'usm public qui après dans
leurs exercices doivent veiller à ce que
cette indépendance se traduisent dans
les choix éditoriaux et notamment termes
d'information ce qui a été pour moi une
tâche essentielle du jour où j'ai été
nommé et je suis appliqué à défendre
ceux de valeur comme étant la valeur
cardinale du service public mais vous
dire aussi et ça nous relient avec le
com que la question de l'indépendance
est aussi très directement liées au mode
de financement et un financement pérenne
et lui même indépendant et je dirais que
de ce point de vue là le fait que dans
la loi il y ait un élément qui
maintiennent la publicité en journée
après 2016 est un élément extrêmement
2015 est un élément extrêmement
important pour nous qui nous permet de
consolider le financement même si je
tiens à le signaler
aujourd'hui le dispositif publicitaire
de france télévisions est un dispositif
publicitaire uniquement journée qui nous
défavorise sur le marché puisque nous
manquons d'espacé publicitaire puissant
que peuvent présenter aux annonceurs nos
nos grands concurrents dire aussi que le
fait que le csa puisse prendre en compte
les équilibres économiques
les conséquences économiques des
décisions d'attribution de canaux ou de
changement de canaux me semble un
élément central
le fait de devoir par le passé donné
faire des appels à candidatures
automatique lorsque des canaux étaient
disponibles sans avoir au préalable des
analyses sur l'impact économique pouvant
créer des situations difficiles pour le
marché en général et pour certaines
chaînes en particulier il me semble que
les équilibres du paysage audiovisuel
sur le plan économique ces équilibres
sont un élément absolument clé du
développement de
les différentes chaînes et donc de la
fiabilité des que des exécutions des
cahiers des charges
enfin dernier point je note que une
commission sur le second dividende
numérique est envisagée dans cette loi
vous savez que cette question de la
bande des 700 et donc du second
dividende numérique est un point sur
lequel je me suis exprimé je tiens à
redire ici que c'est une question
stratégique pour nous est une question
stratégique qui doit nous permettre
demain notamment de développer les
nouvelles technologies et les passages
en hd en particulier mais aussi tout ce
qui permettra l'interactivité ou demain
les nouvelles technologies et le fait de
restreindre les possibilités techniques
de l'audiovisuel sont probablement pas
une meilleure la meilleure des façons de
conforter l'avenir de ces entreprises et
notamment leur capacité à ceux à se
développer
à part cela sur cette loi je n'ai pas
d'autres observations à faire mais
évidemment je pourrai répondre à vos à
vos questions concernant le point que
vous évoquez madame la présidente du
contrat d'objectifs et de moyens nous
avons en effet travaillé avec
le gouvernement est présenté à notre
conseil d'administration un projet
d'avenant au contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens
lors d'une séance du mois de juillet
pourquoi un avenant je rappelle que nous
avions signé un contrat d'objectifs et
de moyens
fin 2011 pour une période qu'ils
allaient jusqu'en 2015 il se trouve que
dans l'intervalle la trajectoire des
ressources a été modifié de façon
importante
cette trajectoire des ressources a été
modifié de façon importante
principalement parce que la ligne
budgétaire qui était la ligne de
compensation à l'arrêt de la publicité
qui je rappelle et est à l'origine de
450 millions a été diminué de façon
importante et les prévisions de
ressources publiques pour les trois
années 2013 2014 2015 étaient des
prévisions à la baisse qui nous
obligeait donc à revoir la trajectoire
économique sachant que parallèlement je
l'évoqué très vite tout à l'heure le
chiffre d'affaires publicitaire est lui
même en baisse et en raison de la crise
économique et en raison des dispositifs
publicitaires que nous pouvons mettre
sur le marché et donc l'ensemble de ces
éléments nous ont conduit à observer à
l'horizon 2015 une baisse des ressources
disponibles de l'ordre de 10% 1 donc 300
millions sur 3 milliard
si je prends des chiffres ronds il est
évident que à partir de là nous étions
tenus de modifier la trajectoire du
contrat d'objectifs et de moyens et la
modifiées aussi avec la prise en compte
des évolutions de notre environnement et
avec un objectif qui est est d'arriver à
l'équilibré économique en 2015 donc une
trajectoire économique modifier des
objectifs à repréciser notamment en
fonction de l'évolution de notre
environnement et un objectif de retour à
l'équilibré en 2015 qui était un élément
central du du travail que nous avons
entrepris ce travail que nous avons
entrepris nous a permis de réaffirmer
les objectifs principaux de l'entreprise
qui sont d'abord d'avoir une offre
différente de ceux de l'offre privée et
une offre qui nous permet de jouer le
double rôle d'information d'une
information indépendante et je reprends
le terme d'indépendance une information
de référence
et puis le lieu de développement delà de
la création création sous toutes ses
formes que ce soit la fiction le
documentaire l'animation le spectacle
vivant le véhicule delà de la culture et
de la création culturelle avec deux
autres objectifs clés qui était le
rapport au territoire et le territoire
pour nous je rappelle que ce sont en
france métropolitaine les régions mais
que c'est aussi l'autre mère puisque
france télévisions est présente sur tous
les territoires ultramarins et la
nécessité de rester le lieu de
présentation de l'offre sportive
gratuite dans un univers où le sport se
développe de plus en plus de manière
payante avec évidemment
pour les chaînes gratuites une
diminution forte de ces événements sauf
sur le service public qui continue à
fédérer grâce à cela donc voilà les
quelques éléments clés en terme de
contenu on pourra y revenir si vous le
souhaitez le tout étant inscrit dans une
profonde évolution quelle évolution du
numérique
l'évolution du numérique qui a deux
caractéristiques la première c'est de
faire en sorte que les images sont
présentes aujourd'hui ceux de multiples
écrans
ces écrans sont aussi bien les écrans de
télévision que les smartphones les
ordinateurs les tablettes et demain
d'après ce qu'on peut voir apparaître
les montres vous avez vu qu'il ya
maintenant une industrie lancé par
samsung qui va être en compétition avec
les américains sur des montres qui
seront demain des supports on peut le
regretter ou le ou l'espérer mais en
tout cas c'est un c'est un fait et donc
la nécessité pour nous service public de
jouer notre rôle qui est d'être présent
sur ces différents supports et être
présent sur ces supports parce que il
faut que nos contenus puisse être vu par
le plus grand nombre pour jouer notre
rôle de deux liens dans la population et
et de diffuseurs encore une fois de
cette différence et je dirais d'ailleurs
de 10 fait de diffuseur de l'exception
culturelle
vous êtes beaucoup battu sur les
questions d'exception culturelle et de
nécessité de défendre et de préserver la
capacité de notre pays à financer les
industries de la création
eh bien ces industries de la création
n'ont de sens que si la création est
diffusé et elle n'est diffusé
aujourd'hui que sur l'audiovisuel public
et donc le
le la lutte la bagarre que vous avez
menées sur la question de l'exception
culturelle se traduit par la nécessité
d'avoir ces vecteurs de diffusion de
cette exception et encore une fois c'est
l'audiovisuel public tout c'est tous ces
éléments-là repréciser avec un certain
nombre de dévolution je pense en
particulier à l'évolution des
positionnements de france 4 et de france
ô est la volonté aussi d'avoir sur
france 3 en région une pause sur les
développements qui était prévu en terme
d'heures de programmes régionaux puisque
nous avions dans le plan 2011 une
croissance continue
nous sommes là sur une stabilité
légèrement à la baisse tous ces éléments
là une fois précisées nous devons
évidemment nous avons dû travailler sur
une trajectoire qui financièrement nous
permettent en faisant des choix
d'arriver à un équilibre que j'indiquais
tout à l'heure alors cette trajectoire
elle se caractérise d'abord par le fait
que nous ferons des économies sur
l'ensemble de nos dépenses avec un plan
d'économies qui a démarré dès l'année
2012 ce qui nous a permis d'ailleurs en
2012 d'être à l'équilibré en 2012 alors
que nous avions 70 millions de recettes
de moins qu'en 2011 nous sommes sortis à
l' équilibre donc c'est bien que nous
avons menées déjà un plan d'économies en
ce plan d'économies général est un plan
d'économies d'abord sur les coûts
externes sur l'ensemble des dépenses
frais généraux de structure sur tous les
achats de programmes et les achats
externes et lorsque je dis achats de
programmes
je dois préciser que ça se traduit par
notamment sur les achats de démission de
flux d audit systématique et des baisses
de coûts négociée qui sont autour de 7 à
8% sur ce que nous avons pu
et
ce ce sur quoi nous avons négocié depuis
un an nous avons surtout les achats
externes aussi une politique maintenant
extrêmement rigoureuse qui nous ont
permis des baisses de prix de l'ordre de
10%
bref un travail global qui doit nous
permettre encore une fois de dégager des
marges sachant que sur les programmes
eux mêmes nous avons d'une part des
grilles de programmes que nous faisons
évoluer en privilégiant un certain
nombre de contenus et en supprimant un
certain nombre d'autres contenus pour
nous permettre encore une fois d'être
l'un des objectifs que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure et le coût de grille globalement
c'est à dire nos dépenses de programmes
vont évoluer sur cette période de -1 1%
par an à peu près donc on a si vous
voulez à partir d'un niveau qui était un
niveau atteint en 2012
une trajectoire qui est globalement de
-1 1% par an cette trajectoire étant une
trajectoire qui d'une part résulte des
négociations que j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure et des politiques d'audit
systématique mais aussi d'un certain
nombre d'arbitrages que nous sommes
amenés à faire sur la période
sachant qu encore une fois ce que nous
avions prévu dans le cadre du contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens signés en 2011
était plutôt une croissance pendant
cette période de l'ordre de 2 à 3 % par
an nous avons aussi sur le plan social
un travail qui est de deux ordres
premier point qui est absolument
centrale c'est que nous avons réussi à
la suite d'une négociation très longue
mais extrêmement fructueuse a signé avec
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
des nouveaux accords d'entreprise qui se
substitue à l'ensemble des conventions
collectives qui existait depuis quelques
dizaines d'années mais aussi qui se
substitue à tous les accords des
différentes entreprises
ce point est absolument centrale parce
que l'entreprise unique france
télévision n'existait pas jusqu'à ce
jour puisque coexistaient des statuts de
personnel différent et ses statuts des
personnels différents faisait qu'il ya
des règlements du travail différent des
ddd manière de d'organiser le travail
différents et donc le fait d'avoir
aujourd'hui un statut commun la suite de
cette négociation nous va nous permettre
de mutualiser plus facilement de faire
passer plus facilement des
collaborateurs d'une structure à l'autre
et donc de nous organiser plus
facilement et nous organiser plus
facilement
c'est permettre le développement mais ça
peut permettre aussi des économies et de
ce point de vue là nous avons déjà
réussi à abaisser de façon sensible nos
effectifs puisque à ce jour si je me
compare au niveau des effectifs moyens
de l'an passé 2012 comparé à l'effectif
moyen des huit premiers mois 2013 nous
sommes globalement à 3 500 personnes de
moins ce qu'on appelle équivalents temps
plein c'est à dire que là où nous étions
à 1 10 un peu plus de 1600 nous sommes
un peu plus de dix mille cent l'objectif
en terme de gestion du personnel
c'est de baisser encore les effectifs et
le plan s'est fixé comme objectifs en
2015 d'arriver à 9750 exactement c'est à
dire par rapport au point haut de dix
mille six cent que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure
850 personnes en moins cette deuxième
phase que nous allons enclencher est une
phase que nous allons être lâchés en
présentant de très prochainement au
comité central d'entreprise le 1er
octobre
activement un un plan de départs
volontaires
mais ce plan de départs volontaires est
un plan de départs fondé sur des
organisations différentes que nous
pouvons faire maintenant
et donc c'est un plan de départ qui doit
se traduire par des départs non
remplacés
une des raisons pour lesquelles les
plans de départs passé notamment le
dernier qui avait été lancée juste avant
mon arrivée était un plan de départ vous
en souvenez peut-être d'accélération de
départ à la retraite qui donc n'était
pas centré sur une organisation nouvelle
et qui a fait que nous avons eu beaucoup
de remplacements
les effectifs vont donc baisser avec
dans ses effectifs qui baisse en
particulier un point très important pour
nous qui est le point de la baisse de
l'emploi non permanents à sept emplois
non permanents étaient de l'ordre de 19
% de nos effectifs
france télévision dans les années 2010
2011 et 2012 nous avons baisser ce taux
l'ordre de 16% à ce jour nous continuons
à faire ce travail sachant que
parallèlement à la négociation qui va
être lancée sur les questions de deux
plans de départs volontaires
nous lançons nous lançons une
négociation sur les questions de
l'emploi non permanent lié aussi au
débat sur l'intermittence et nous aurons
aussi un une négociation sur les
questions de l'emploi senior comme
toutes les entreprises aujourd'hui le
fond et dans le cadre de la loi
notamment globalement aujourd'hui la
trajectoire que nous avons fixés dans le
cadre de ce contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens est une trajectoire qui comporte
toute une série d' aller à ces aléas
sont au moins deux de trois principaux
premier aléas
c'est évidemment là léa publicitaire de
cet aléa publicitaire est liée à notre
situation je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
une offre qui n'est qu'une offre en
journée elle y est aussi
à l'évolution de la concurrence est liée
aussi à l'évolution de la situation
économique
ce point est un point aujourd'hui
préoccupant pour nous parce que nous
nous rendus compte que à fin août alors
que nous avions déjà une prévision
publicitaire sensiblement en retrait par
rapport aux réalisé 2012 qui lui même
était déjà en retrait nous sommes
aujourd'hui à fin août avec un budget
réalisé de l'ordre de 10 millions en
dessous delà de l'objectif 2013 donc on
vous nous voyons qu'on a une difficulté
concernant la publicité 2e aller à cet
effectif mans liées au financement
public et en particulier à la ligne
subvention qui est inscrite dans le dans
le budget de l'état
je rappelle que sur cette ligne par
exemple par rapport au budget qui a été
voté pour l'année 2013 en cours il y a
aujourd'hui une somme de 31 millions qui
a gelé et nous subissons en quelque
sorte le même traitement que les
administrations
alors que nous sommes dans des contrats
dans ces contrats la ressource publique
est un des éléments de de fonctionnement
et déquilibre donc aujourd'hui non
seulement nous avons des millions de
moins opulent publicité mais
potentiellement 31 millions de moins en
recettes publiques lesquelles recettes
publiques ont par ailleurs été déterminé
encore une fois dans le cadre du budget
et puis troisième aller à celle aléas
liés au plan de départ puisque ce sera
un plan de départs volontaires
et qui dit plan de départs volontaires
dit donc nécessité d'avoir dans le cadre
que nous fixons des personnes qu'ils
souhaitent partir qu'ils acceptent de
partir et de ce point de vue même si
je suis optimiste je pense que nous il
ya peu nous dire et nous y réussiront la
prudence veut que nous ayons donc cet
aléa que nous prenions en compte tout
cela fait que j'ai proposé au
gouvernement qui l'a accepté que ce plan
soit enfin ce contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens soit révisable ce qui veut dire
en substance que nous faisons comme les
grands groupes industriels des plans
stratégiques qui sont des plans glissant
et ça me semble raisonnable parce
qu'aujourd'hui dire j'ai un contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens et dans ce
contrat d'objectifs et de moyens sur
période moyenne ou longue
là en l'occurrence et trois ans mais ça
pouvait être cinq ans je fige les choses
alors que mon environnement bougent et
qu'en particulier l'état qui est
signataire de ce contrat peut être à
même de ne pas respecter les les
éléments de recettes ou la publicité
connaître les difficultés que je viens
d'évoquer
je crois qu'il est sage encore une fois
comme tout groupe industriel de se dire
et c'est ce que nous avons inscrit dans
ce contrat que nous donnons rendez vous
par exemple chaque année où la
discussion du budget pour analyser les
éléments constitutifs du budget à venir
et voir s'il ya des évolutions
significatives des risques importants et
donc modifié en quelque sorte à ce
moment là les objectifs et nous
permettre de cette façon-là de rester en
ligne avec les objectifs économiques et
en particulier avec l'absolue nécessité
d'être à l'équilibré en 2015 parce que
une entreprise qui ne trouve pas son
équilibre économique à un moment donné
est une entreprise qui bien sûr perd son
indépendance mais aussi ne peut pas
continuer à investir alors cette
question est une question qui modifie
quelque peu le rapport au contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens mais c'est
aussi une question qui doit nous
permettre chaque année lorsque nous
présentons à vous
le bad précisément faire le point et de
voir quelles sont les évolutions
voilà madame la présidente les quelques
éléments en introduction merci monsieur
le président donc vous avez vraiment
conformément comme je vois là je vous le
suggérez aborder les deux phases à la
fois la loi et le contrat d'objectifs
dont tout de suite afin que nous
puissions tenir notre horaire je passe
la parole à notre rapporteur david
assouline
et puis ensuite aux collègues qui
voudront vous interroger sur ou l'autre
de ces deux aspects oui merci madame la
présidente je film narre l'audition à
l'origine porte essentiellement sur ce
projet de loi qui nous arrive nous avons
délai assez rapprochées pour pouvoir le
travail et dans notre commission avant
son passage en séance publique et donc
je vous remercie de deux d'avoir trouvé
le temps de cette audition et vient
percuter cette audition
quelque chose qui nous tient à coeur
notamment dans notre commission de
pouvoir regarder étudié donner un avis
sur les com est là un avenant au comme
je voudrais dire que je suis désolé pas
content et il faudra plus que ça se
reproduise et peut-être qu'il faudra le
mettre dans la loi que on puisse une
fois de plus avoir un avenant au com -
comme qui arrive à la fin du mois de
juillet
comme il faut quatre semaines pour entre
na vi ou six semaines que nous soyons
nous en situation puisque les mois les
semaines du mois d'août
ben on n'est pas là pour le voir le
découvrir en entrant et de voir tout de
suite dire oui ou non
je les dis dans le passé c'était un
autre gouvernement je le redis
cette fois ci avec la même insistance
par respect pour ce rôle qu'a le
parlement et notre commission et
d'ailleurs donc il faudra peut-être
mettre dans la loi que c'est même
réduire le délai on n'a pas besoin de
six semaines mais que ça commence à
l'ouverture de la session qui suit quand
on ne reçoit en fermeture de session et
requins et quatre semaines soit pas
mangé par le moment où le parlement
n'est pas là où c'est une mise au point
pour vous dire que par sérieux je ne
vais pas rentrer dans l'avenant même si
j'en ai j'ai quelques informations mais
je n'ai pas eu encore le temps de le
lire en même temps que il fallait
préparer travailler de façon importante
sur la loi donc j'ai bien vu que sur la
loi vous êtes heureux que
l'indépendance soit confortée donc il y
a et vous insistez sur le fait que
l'indépendance pour vous c'est pas que
pour nous aussi bien sûr on l'a dit fort
que l'indépendance des responsables de
l'audiovisuel mais mais l'indépendance
financière
ça viendra en son temps en discussion
globale c'est des débats que nous avons
eus au moment de la loi de 2009
c'est un point de vue que j'ai défendue
fortement considéré que l'indépendant se
reposer d'abord parce qu'on était sur
deux pieds la redevance qui n'était pas
complètement l'état puisque c'était une
un prélèvement direct est pas chaque
année
dotation budgétaire nous savions qu'il y
avait la moitié qui venait du commerce
et donc on était assez indépendant des
deux puisqu'on dépendez d'aucun
complètement
maintenant ce paysage s'est modifié et
c'est évident que pas pour qu une
question d'indépendance mais pour une
question de pérennité et j'en viens au
comme donc de cette façon il faut
absolument qu'on puisse dans
l'audiovisuel public à partir d'une
stratégie à partir de riz comme être sûr
que les deux partenaires et notamment la
source de financement soit là pour
l'accompagner jusqu'aux mots et
l'instabilité ou l'incertitude chaque
année renouvelée et là on est tombé en
plein dans les incertitudes et ça
condamne d'ailleurs la loi telle qu'elle
avait été conçue à l'époque les faits
l'ont condamné plus que les a priori et
j'en avais
et ça nous met dans cette difficulté
donc moi et nous sénat s'est battu
l'année dernière pour que la redevance
soit encore plus partie prenante du
financement puisque augmentation déjà
prévu nous avions proposé deux euros de
plus qu il faisait 50 millions plus
c'est ce qui faisait que vous puissiez
passer ce cap
je tiens à le souligner qu'ils étaient
très difficiles le conseil budgétaire ça
voilà sur le comme j'ai dit et sur
l'indépendance je voudrais je suis
embêté pourquoi parce que j'aurais aimé
que mais ça vous met dans une situation
difficile forcément poser une question
qui a toute sa place mais en même temps
qui est à la peine de vous une position
personnelle un regard personnel sur
quelque chose qui vous concerne
j'avais envie de vous poser la question
mais vous pouvez ne pas y répond quel
regard vous portez à posteriori sur le
mode de nomination qui a conduit à votre
propre nomination
voilà peut-être qu'avec l'expérience
pouvez-vous dire voilà c'est cesser nous
dire comment vous l'avez ressenti dans
l'exercice de votre fonction je parle
pas en soi cette loi est un peu plus
importante que la simple nomination
puisque voulant que le csa soit aussi
indépendant puisque c'est lui qui on
reprend la nomination qu'on ne voulait
pas revenir au sein du comté c'est à
dire en gros c'est pas le président qui
nomme c'est le sable on serait rentré
dans le débat mais elle cesse à lui-même
est-il indépendant et donc le changement
de mode de nomination au csa est quelque
chose qui est important et donc on a
touché aussi aux statuts du csa et à un
certain nombre de ses fonctions et d2 et
de ses nécessités d'attribution pour une
meilleure régulation dans un
environnement qui a beaucoup bougé
à partir de cette constatation à
l'assemblée on a été
un peu plus loin puisque la loi a doublé
de volume ici on va essayer de baladou
et encore parce que ce serait aller
contre nos principes de ne pas faire des
lois trop verbeuse mais en même temps
voilà des champs où étaient ouverts et
ont suscité les nouveaux débats donc je
voulais vous demander mais là plus comme
pas trop de le secteur de l'audiovisuel
pas forcément au public mais vous avez
un regard sur l'ensemble de
l'audiovisuel
quel est votre point de vue qui n'est
pas directement concernée quoique sur
cet amendement qui est arrivé à
l'assemblée nationale proposant que le
csa puisse attribuer une chaîne de la
tnt payante
la faire glisser en tête et gratuite
puisque c'est un des sujets qui abat qui
a occupé le plus les autres patrons de
visuels que j'ai auditionné la semaine
dernière et je vais continuer à les
auditionner certains disent c'est le
pluralisme qui s'accomplit encore plus
d'autres qui disent que le marché saturé
que forcément certains vous vos tombes
et que les études économiques montrent
qu'il n'y a pas la place pour pour plus
votre point de vue vous comme pas trop
et et acteurs de l'audiovisuel public
ensuite
quel aveu quel est à votre avis doivent
être les liens entre france télévisions
avec et le csa dès lors qu'il sera en
charge de la nomination de son président
êtes vous favorable par exemple à ce que
ce qui n'est pas aujourd'hui prévue par
la loi ils puissent aussi donner un avis
sur l'exécution du com et j'ai tant ma
question à quelque chose qui est présent
dans le projet qui nous arrive et qui
est qu'au moment des agglos candidature
pour la nomination des présidents
le deuxième les auditions de
l'audiovisuel public
ils soient porteurs d'un projet
d'orientation et qu'on juge la personne
et le projet d'orientation et ensuite
qu'ils soient déclinées dans les trois
mois après une nomination de façon plus
programmatique on va dire mais ça a
manqué et je pense que c'est bien que ça
se sont introduits dans cette loi pour
penser vous est ce que ça aurait été un
processus qui vous aurait même plus
armés aidés
si vous aviez été dès l'origine et en
vous portant
pas complètement la peau des natures
mais en tous les cas à cette fonction
est ce que ça aurait aidé moi je pense
que c'est une bonne chose et je vous
pose la question
voilà je jeu ya beaucoup de questions
sur le code nous on va le discuté en
commission je crois la semaine prochaine
vous vous remettra à notre avis mettra
surtout sur la place publique à l'état
et à vous mais je pense que ce serait
passé à notre part de le faire semblant
qu'on a un avis sur quelque chose qu'on
n'a pas étudié la seule chose sur lequel
je veux déjà voté c'est que les annonces
de suppressions d'emplois ou plutôt de
postes
les centaines et ses terrasses et des
chiffres qui qui pèse et qui ont leur
importance
en tous les cas moi je serai
particulièrement attentif et je vous
pose la question surtout aux plus
concret
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour résorber
l'emploi non permanents à france
télévisions voilà on peut pas et d'un
côté ba supprimer des postes et
maintenir ce qui est un peu
contradictoire
un tel volume d'emplois non permanents à
france télévisions et je le dis d'autant
plus que si on va au bout de ce que le
sénat veut faire en général c'est à dire
aurait étudié cette question départ de
cow prod l internalisation plus grande
pour france télévisions comme pour tout
non mais il faudra des salariés
si vous voulez bien à monsieur président
répondre à ces interrogations du
rapporteur et apprend passera la parole
mon collègue
merci madame la présidente je vais
répondre à toutes ces questions bien sûr
important en répondant la première vous
dire que du jour où j'ai été nommée la
question de l'indépendance de france
télévisions était ma question centrale
parce que j'avais une expérience j'avais
dirigé france 3 pendant six ans je
n'étais pas 30 presse presse quotidienne
régionale donc un média qui joue un rôle
très important dans sa région et et la
crédibilité de l'entreprise de presse au
sens large et de la deuxième public en
particulier elle repose d'abord sur
l'indépendance et ma mission était de
garantir cette indépendance et je les
fais de façon très naturelle et
d'ailleurs au sein de l'entreprise sans
le moindre doute peut-être de par ma
façon de fonctionner mais aussi de par
mon histoire et la façon dont les gens
connaissaient ma pratique et directe de
ce point de vue là la manière dont nous
avons traité des élections
présidentielle et législatives en 2012
à france télévisions ont montré que
cette question d'indépendance était tout
à fait au coeur de nos préoccupations
qu'il était garantie je note d'ailleurs
que pour l'ensemble de ces élections
nous n'avons eu aucune observation du
csa à l'époque d'aucune sorte pour
autant et ça c'est donc là que pour
répond tout à fait précisément sur
l'exercice de la fonction est encore une
fois la manière dont j'ai ressenti les
choses par rapport à cette question de
l'indépendance après que lors des
premiers mois
la question récurrente du mode de
nomination a été répondu et souvent de
façon très irritantes pouvait être un
handicap ou où je dirais une gêne
peut-être j'en sais rien en tout cas pas
dans ma pratique mais dans l'image
donnée je dirais qu'en tout cas ce point
là est un point qui va disparaître avec
ce mode de nomination mais
mais je voudrais insister peut-être sur
un point c'est que être garant de
l'indépendance est non seulement être
nommé d'une certaine façon mais avoir
une pratique de l'exercice de patrons
presse patrons de médias qui dépasse
largement le mode de nomination et qui
est lié et à la personnalité et à
l'expérience et à l'expérience et aux
rapports qu'on a avec la mission et et
notamment le rôle qu'ont joué dans la
dans la société sur les questions que
vous vous posez concernant l'amendement
transfert des chaînes payantes vers le
vers le gratuit
moi je me félicite de ce que le csa est
pour mission à partir de cette loi
d'analyser les impacts économiques avant
de prendre une décision d'attribution de
transfert je pense qu'on peut pas avoir
de position de principe en disant il
faut pouvoir transférer ou pas transféré
il faut pouvoir créer ou pas créé en
revanche je pense qu'il faut avoir une
vision très claire des impacts sur
l'environnement et une vision très
claire de la viabilité de l'autorisation
qu'on donne parce que en affaiblissant
l'environnement ou en amenant telle ou
telle chaîne qui aurait des équilibres
économiques trop fragile a cessé son
activité
on perturbe gravement l'équilibré du
paysage et on perturbe gravement en
particulier parce que alors c'est moi
notre cas mais c'est plus le cas des
chaînes privées on perturbe le marché
publicitaire parce que vous pouvez avoir
à ce moment là des comportements sur le
marché publicitaire qui sont notamment
des comportements de 2 de baisse de prix
enfin et c qui perturbent le marché et
on est sur un marché où il ya des enjeux
importants d'emploi où il ya des enjeux
importants en termes de création et
lorsqu'on donne une autorisation
lorsqu'on permet un service de 2,2 de se
développer
au vu de d'obligations de cahier des
charges de missions définies par le csa
ou avec le csa est que à la fin des
courses la situation que le mec est
tellement dégradée qu'on ne parvient pas
à remplir ses missions je pense que la
question mérite la mérite d'être posée
en tout cas l'analyse qui devrait être
fait des conséquences doit être
extrêmement fouillée et non seulement
analysé sur l'immédiateté la situation
mais une projection à quelques années
concernant le rapport d'exécution du
code que nous présenterons au csa moi je
suis très favorable à ce que la
situation à la solution qui a été
trouvée c'est à dire une présentation au
csa qui évidemment peut faire ses
observation mais aussi une présentation
au sénat et à l'assemblée nationale ça
me semble extrêmement important et je
souhaitais en tout cas qui est cet
équilibre pour garder le contact avec
les élus qu'ils quand même pour moi sont
la légitimité de la nation et nous
sommes la télévision delà de la nation
vous avez évoqué le l'emploi non
permanents oui nous lançons 3
négociations simultanées une négociation
sur le plan de départs volontaires
une négociation sur l'emploi non
permanents et la réduction sept emplois
non permanents avec des objectifs de
réduction importants qui doivent nous
permettre avec une nouvelle organisation
du travail de faire baisser cette
emplois non permanents mais aussi avec
une perspective lié à l'intermittence
qui sera très directement conséquente de
la conséquence des d'eads et des
discussions qui auront lieu et et des
lois qui éventuellement seront votées
mais le taux de recours à l'emploi non
permanents qui a déjà baissé de quelques
points au cours des mois qui viennent de
se passer doit continuer à diminuer vous
verrez dans le code l'avenant au contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens que nous nous
fixons d'ailleurs une baisse du taux de
recours à l'emploi non permanents de
façon assez sensible puisque là nous
étions autour de 18 19 % nous souhaitons
aller en dessous de 15%
sachant que dans sept emplois non
permanents
il y a évidemment toute une partie qui
est lié à des activités de la télévision
comme des productions événementiel etc
qui est un élément clé effectivement de
la gestion mais nous devons absolument
diminuer fortement l'emploi non
permanents qui est plutôt permanent fins
que vous évoquiez me sera porteur et les
deux choses m'ont de dvd de choses vont
de pair merci beaucoup dont il nous
reste un carter pour que
que vous puissiez mes chers collègues
nous poser les questions dont je ne peux
que vous recommander de les poser de
façon synthétique afin que personne ne
soit frustré voilà qui souhaitent
prendre la parole rapidement puisque
l'on va très peu de temps et l'audition
que nous avons aujourd'hui concerne le
sujet peut-être un peu lié mais au fond
assez différent un la loi relatif à
l'indépendance de l'audiovisuel et le
cob de france télévisions je pense que
c'est pas forcément le bon périmètre
pour parler de la loi sur la dépendance
de l'audivisuel je ferai quand même un
motif en observation sur ce sur ce mot
merveilleux dont le rapporte à souligner
parfois l'ambiguïté le moins dépendance
c'est un très beau mot ça doit être le
plus le mot le plus prononcé dans les
débats des assemblées mais c'est un mot
dangereux puisque que qui est
indépendant commandé fille définit-on
d'indépendance on aura en aura d'autres
occasions de parler de cette
indépendance dans la volonté du
gouvernement actuel de revoir la
nomination des présidents de
l'audiovisuel
je ne suis pas certain que les
l'indépendance à mieux assurer dans la
loi que vous projetez étant moi même
administrateur de france télévisions
je peux témoigner de l'effort constant
du président sortant que je salue dans
son souci de respecter cet esprit
d'indépendance et j'aimerais bien que le
rapporteur pour la même question qu'il a
posée à monsieur philippe blain tout à
l'heure à au président du csa pour
savoir comment lui il a ressenti sa
nomination par le président de la
république ça serait intéressant
d'entendre également sa réponse mais je
pense que c'est pas le lieu de
l'audition du président
de traiter de ce sujet revenons-en
rapidement au comme 3 3 trois éléments
essentiels
l'objectif d' équilibre en 2015
et dans cet objectif être les les points
les dépenses et nos recettes je crois
que ce que vous projetez quand vous
parlez d'un nouveau concept en réalité
deux comme glissant un sujet intéressant
ce nouveau concept comme glissant bon ça
peut définir des grands autorisation met
donc quand on connaît pas les chiffres
et leur évolution c'est difficile de
respecter des données figé à un moment
donné alors que l'environnement change
l'objectif me semble devoir être de
stabiliser les choses et les recettes
aléatoires
qu'elles soient de nature publicitaire
ou qu'elles soient de nature de dotation
au public sur le budget me paraissent
devoir être à un moment donné plus
plus précisément défini nous vous le
savez on a été longtemps et je crois que
là tu sénat était assez assez consensuel
il yal'affaire de la publicité alors
c'est sûr que c'est une recette
qu'aujourd'hui france télévisions
souhaite garder je suis pas certain qu'à
long terme
ce soit la bonne solution pour assurer
la stabilité de la recette
nous avons toujours préféré distinguer
le service public du service
concurrentiel en dispensant france
télévisions de 2,7 mamére la complète on
parle pas là là ce qu'on appelait la
redevance et qui est devenue la
contribution il n'est pas dans l'esprit
aujourd'hui de nos concitoyennes
compatriotes
l'idée d'augmenter considérablement mais
je voudrais poser la question au
président dont je connais l'orientation
qui est de devoir maintenir la publicité
voire aurait augmenté les créneaux de
diffusion bien vrai sujet puisqu'on
parle d'indépendance pas de
l'indépendance par rapport à la
publicité il ya aussi des annonceurs qui
peuvent être influent on peut le penser
en tout cas que penserait-il si la
situation de la nation et du budget de
la france était aujourd'hui un peu plus
souple de revenir à une notion de
financement de france télévisions
davantage par la contribution par
d'anciennes redevance plutôt que par un
budget plus une ressource publicitaire
plus plus aléatoire et est ce que vous
pensez monsieur le président que la
recherche la compétition pour la
recherche de la publicité dans un marché
qui est forcément contraint aujourd'hui
copula situation économique est ce que
si on si on trouvait le compensation par
la redevance est ce que quel serait
votre approche du à la suppression
totale de la publicité à la télévision
publique
posez les questions pour qu'on soit sûr
voilà qu'en puissent après tenir
l'horaire alors qu'il souhaitait encore
intervenir monsieur gattolin merci
madame la présidente merci monsieur le
président de syna moi j'ai quelques
questions qui concernent à la fois
effectivement l'avenant au comme que
nous découvrons est ce que j'arrête là
très bien exprimer monsieur le
rapporteur et c'est quelque chose je
crois récurrent dans cette commission
découvre soit les comme soit les
avenants dans des conditions d'études
qui sont quand même absolument délicate
et ça pose problème
en regardant l'avenant lui-même et en le
comparant aux comme tels qu'ils étaient
produits donc on avait eu l'occasion de
survoler non pas d'étudier au début de
la nouvelle mandature
je vois très peu de variantes et je vois
toujours la même structure
c'est une continuité et je trouve qu'il
manque flagrant quand on est le service
public on a quand même des vocations ou
alors elle sent très mal exprimé a
touché puisque c'est le contribuable
c'est le citoyen à ses missions de
service public le plus grand nombre et
le plus large panel de la population
quand on va en page 23 la répartition
par tranche d'âge de l'audience de
france télévisions on a un
vieillissement considérable et quand
vous et vieux qui et les difficultés de
la ressource publicitaire bien sûr il ya
la concurrence
globalement jusqu'à présent
l'investissement publicitaire en france
sur la télévision n'a jamais décrue sauf
peut-être après la crise immédiate de
2008 mais ça s'est relativement redressé
ce que je note c'est qu'en revanche
france télévisions dans son évolution de
l'audience qui globalement est à la
baisse
puisqu'il ya la concurrence de la tnt
d'internet et la concurrence aussi
d'aider des autres chaînes plus
généralement voit ses cibles justement
moins de 50 ans qui sont à la fois des
objectifs de service public et qui sont
aussi des cibles entre guillemets
d'audience marchande dégringoler donc
moi je ne suis pas étonné effectivement
que vous nous expliquer qu'à fin août
nous soyons à -10% et j'en reviens sur
le com et pour terminer et illustrer
cela que penseriez-vous dans le cadre
d'une nouvelle loi que l'on envisage
qu'une feuille de route en amont de la
nomination des six nations choix des
présidents une feuille de route précise
de l'état actionnaire sur des
orientations stratégiques en gros faire
une télévision pour tout le monde avec
comment on fixe des normes de qualité de
missions de service public que le
président tous les cas le candidat ou
les candidats à la présidence des
chaînes fasse effectivement une
proposition un projet véritablement
stratégique
ensuite le comme une école réalisation
et le suivi de tout ça alors
qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans une
situation un petit peu inversé ou en
gros il ya des candidats
il n'y a pas une branche à une vraie
définition préalable des objectifs
généraux et on a un code qui se
retrouvent
une discussion plus ou moins précises
entre le nouveau président de france
télévision ou de la chaîne publique et
l'état des moyens budgétaires dans
lequel le csa n'a pas grand chose à dire
alors moi je me demande si c'est au delà
de la question de l'indépendance des
nomination des présidents de chaînes
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une procédure si
on veut que le travail qu'ils soient
faire au travers des services publics
compris pour aider les présidents des
chaînes doit être au préalable cadrés et
qu'on ait de véritables indicateurs de
performance parce que dans dans l'avion
ou comme il ya deux pages sur à peine ya
une page sur l'audience avec quelques
tableaux on a un kalimat excusez moi
pour connaître ce que font les pays
étrangers et pas seulement la bbc une
petite étude ponctuelles réalisées un
baromètre de quelques questions fait par
l'ifop pour moi ce n'est pas la
satisfaction du public ça ne paraît pas
suffisant pour évaluer des performances
on peut évaluer des performances
d'entreprises
est ce que l'entreprise est bien géré et
bien organisé et ce qu'elle les logiques
sociales qui sont conformes aux
objectifs
on peut évaluer sa production et là on a
des éléments sur la production par
contre sur sa réception sur le public je
trouve que on oublie le destinataire
final qui est l'usagé qui est le
téléspectateur et qui est le citoyen
contribue à merci alors
oui elle nous avons évoqué de le com et
puis le texte de loi qui arrive sur la
dépendance
il y a aussi un autre texte de loi qui
arrive la semaine prochaine savoir le
texte de najat vallaud belkacem sur
évidemment la juste représentation des
femmes dans les programmes des services
de communication audiovisuelle est
également à l'image les stéréotypes la
lutte contre les stéréotypes et les
préjugés sexistes
donc là également je rejoins je rejoins
le notre collègue david assouline
lorsqu'il dit que on l'a très
tardivement le corps mais on peut pas
évidemment l'analyse est correctement
donc ça c'est un des points qui va être
aussi un à regarder et à vérifier en
matière donc de parité autre chose je
voudrais évoquer france 3 france 3 je
crois qu'il y à une réforme qui est
prévue pour 2015 et vous avez évoqué des
baisses des programmes régionaux
sachez que nous sommes tous très très
attachés évidemment à nous à nos
territoires et qu'il faudra de fond mené
une réflexion sur la place
évidemment que doit jouer france 3 ainsi
que sur la place de la diffusion
régionale sur sur cette antenne
d'autre part vous avez évoqué et david
l'a fait également les emplois non
permanents vous avez la volonté de les
baisser en ayant recours pour certains
une certaine partie d'entre eux à des
sociétés de production qui sont des
sociétés va tout à fait privé
qui utilise évidemment du personnel
comme elles l'entendent
maintenant est-ce que vous allez
développer par contre dès cdi et je le
dis parce que j'ai auditionné des
membres de france télévisions dans le
cadre de mon travail sur l'intermittence
comment allez-vous développer les
emplois non par non permanents si ce
n'est vous vous les mettez à la porte ou
les renouveler pas où vous vouliez fait
embaucher par les sociétés privées ont
lassé de ce sont des choses tout à fait
intéressante à connaître et puis en
matière de spectacle vivant
vous avez une obligation je crois que
vous respectez votre obligation en
matière de spectacle vivant avec un
équilibre entre les différents genres de
spectacles peut être veiller à ce que la
retransmission des spectacles soient
plus régulièrement répartie est-ce que
souvent il ya des spectacles qui sont
sur france 4
deschesne humoristique et alors que les
chaînes privées
le font très souvent donc essayer de
garder quand même une spécificité de
service public par rapport aux services
privés par rapport au privé
voilà je m'arrête là parce que voilà moi
moi je me permets de rajouter juste
utile focus par rapport à quelque chose
là que vous avez évoquées qui est par
rapport à donc à la place des femmes à
la représentation des femmes comment on
peut arriver à concilier avec toutes les
contraintes qui sont les vôtres
les retransmissions sportives ou certes
les femmes excellent mais où on a
conscience qu en termes d'audience et
peut-être donc pour vous d'intérêt du
public
il y a tout un chemin tout un chemin à
faire
et est ce que c'est un chantier que vous
vous proposer d'ouvrir
voilà merci madame la présidente
concernant le financement
je veux dire à monsieur le que
évidemment si nous nous situons sur le
moyen terme la stabilité et la nécessité
pour l'entreprise publique de remplir
ses missions parce que la grande
différence entre une entreprise de
télévision privée d'une entreprise
publique mais vous l'avez évoqué les uns
les autres c'est que nous avons un
certain nombre de missions et ses
missions sont des missions qui décident
de l'investissement à moyen long terme
sur la création sur l'information il
faudrait donc on a besoin effectivement
d'un financement stable pérenne et
prévisible et le financement stable
pérenne et prévisible c'est d'abord la
redevance c'est d'abord évidemment le
la contribution est de ce point de vue
là je pense qu'il est indispensable
c'est que vous y avez travaillé que
cette contribution voit son assiette
modifier parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
passé dans un autre monde ce qu'ont fait
les allemands les suisses les finlandais
vous les suédois en prenant en compte
l'intégralité des foyers qui ont des
écrans fin donc oui il faut que nous
soyons d'abord financé par la redevance
oui ou par la contribution où il faut en
changer l'assiette probablement et est
en tout cas là la faire évoluer de façon
à nous permettre de de nous développer
après est ce que nous devons choisir un
modèle 100% redevance ou un modèle mixte
je note aujourd'hui que la
quasi-totalité des pays visa par la bbc
ont des modèles mixtes y compris
l'allemagne puisque l'allemagne à de la
publicité pour pour partie je dirais que
ce sont les moyens quels moyens choisir
moi je préfère aujourd'hui un moyen qui
me permettent d'avoir une véritable
stabilité par rapport à mes missions
donc d'abord une redevance la plus forte
possible après s'il peut y avoir un peu
de dynamique commerciale de la part de
la publicité pourquoi pas mais ça ne
doit pas être l'essentiel
sachant que je voudrais préciser de
façon très claire que à france
télévisions jamais un annonceur n'a eu
une influence sur un contenu est ce qui
fait d'ailleurs que nous avons toute une
série d'émissions d'investigation de
consommation qui ont aidé des succès
auprès du public et de la presse mais
c'est un grand débat qu'il faudrait
qu'on poursuive concernant les questions
de nos objectifs enfin je pense
globalement votre propos d'abord eu
lorsque j'ai été nommé président de
france télévision je l'a été après avoir
présenté ma vision ici même et cette
vision elle a été débattue et dans cette
vision j'avais toute une série de points
que nous avons mises en oeuvre dont le
fait de nous adresser à tout le monde et
en particulier pour nous adresser à tout
le monde le fait de devenir un acteur
déterminant du monde numérique
je note que sont aujourd'hui trois ans
après nous sommes leaders sur le plan du
numérique dans ce pays et cet essai
important
après avoir présenté cette vision que
j'avais présenté ici j'ai fait un plan
stratégique et c'est ce plan stratégique
a donné lieu aux comme donc c'est assez
proche de la démarche que vous avez
indiquée j'aurais d'ailleurs vous
indiquez aussi qu'avant que nous ne
travaillons sur le com j'ai refait une
version de mon plan stratégique que j'ai
présenté à mon conseil d'administration
qui l'a approuvé et c'est à partir de là
qu'on m'a de modifier les codes donc on
est bien dans cette démarche là avec un
certain nombre d'objectifs alors oui
nous devons nous adresser à tout le
monde mais oui aussi le monde des médias
traditionnels aujourd'hui que ce soit la
presse écrite que ce soit la télévision
que ce soit la radio s'adresse de plus
en plus à des adultes qui ont
globalement au dessus de 40 ans parce
que oui
les adolescents et les jeunes adultes
consomment de plus en plus des médias et
notamment les nouveaux médias lors nous
souhaitons les aborder de deux manières
d'abord en ayant ce travail sur le
numérique que nous sommes en train de
faire la télévision de rattrapage des
nouvelles écritures etc
vous verrez dans l'avenant comme que
nous avons là dessus un projet sur
france 4 que je pourrais vous présentez
nous doit nous permettre d'aller vers
ces nouveaux publics
et oui nous devons être de plus en plus
présents et nous sommes sur les réseaux
sociaux pour nous permettre de faire
circuler de jouer l'interactivité de
faire en sorte que nous nous inscrivions
bien dans le monde dans lequel nous
sommes alors ce point est central jeu
peut-être juste un point le kalimat
c'est pas quelques questions le kalimat
c'est tout
jour les prime time non seulement du
service public mais aussi de tf1 et de
france 2 qui sont analysées par un panel
représentatif daris avec des données
extrêmement bon je crois que j'ai
débordé bord des montants je voudrais
simplement peut-être une vie moins une
minute parce que c'est pour avait
commencé comme ça excuse on nous a fait
commencé en retard c'est notre
responsabilité le point extrêmement
important sur la représentation des
femmes
j'ai pris des engagements lors d'une
journée que nous avons consacré à cette
question d'ailleurs en présence de la
ministre
najat vallaud belkacem et de madame
aurélie filippetti j'ai pris des
engagements très fermes en termes
d'évolution de la structure de l'emploi
la place des cadres femmes dans la sauce
et puis de l'antenne où j'ai pris
notamment un engagement très fort qui
est que sur l'ensemble des émissions
fait appel à des experts
nous aurons dans le cadre du code au
moins 30% d'experte femmes
donc c'est un engagement formel que nous
avons inscrit dans le com et kiev ont
damé mais je vais vous dire qui est
fondamental comme la question de la
bible voilà pour les travaux de la
commission de la culture qui a
auditionné cette semaine le pdg de
france télévisions dans le cadre du
projet de loi relatifs à l'indépendance
de l'audiovisuel public tout de suite
c'est de 24 heures ces normes